lebanon's diaspora is sending cash home
an estimated 7 billion dollars a year
it's become a Lifeline for many families
affected by the economy's collapse
stories of Despair are all too common
the currency crash made salaries
worthless even the rich lost their
Savings in insolvent Banks and while the
money has had a positive impact on
people's lives the United Nations
development program warns the financial
inflows won't put Lebanon back on the
track
remittances become a phenomenon that we
know as the Dutch disease whereby
unproductive Financial flows help to
maintain dysfunctional systems because
they give people the means to survive
that otherwise a government should
provide
the international community's support
has prevented a nearly bankrupt state
from All Out collapse but there is
growing concern about the lack of
transparency in governance where data is
not always available that includes money
transfers through services such as
Western Union or omt what you really
need is data from omps particularly that
could that could help if the government
is willing to again ask these or MPS for
example to provide data so one can study
this this is a very good way of actually
doing that at least for the portion of
the money that's coming you can can have
a sense of the number of beneficiaries
as a result of the financial meltdown
Lebanon has become a cash economy and
increasingly informal newly adopted
monetary policies seem to be benefiting
those in power
Lebanon has the highest amount of
transfer costs of remittances in the
world the global average stands at six
percent
of the transfer here in Lebanon 11 of
each transfer goes into the transfer
cost
the economic crisis is now in its fourth
year Lebanese say politicians have done
little to alleviate their difficult
living conditions instead inequalities
are only deepening Beirut